je vois la pcm prise de conscience par
le mouvement là je me moque pas de
l'humain mais la convention sociale tout
ça c'est des petits exercices qui vise à
décrisper le la longue c'est très bien
tout ça je m'attendais c'est vrai à une
sorte de coaching un tout petit peu plus
conventionnel
voilà ce qu'est ce que vous allez bien
qu'est ce que j'ai mais vous avez un
truc rouge à l'oreille parce que là mais
c'est une petite tumeur au je
vais crever au nom elle a fait ça j'ai
dit tu meurs tu voulais dire eu l'heur
comme dans bonne humeur bon écoute et
une seule on parle pas je suis doctorat
en sociologie
enfin c'est vrai que vous avez des
références c'est sûr mais franchement
entre nous sincèrement ça marche mais
qui aime les clowns personnes thème des
clous même les enfants aiment pas les
clowns quand j'interviens avec des
enfants malades à l'hôpital
j'arrive à leur faire oublier qu'ils en
ont plus pour très longtemps oui ça
marche
petit sourire pour un petit malin acteur
porno n'est pas l'hôpital ici non mais
c'est la même mécanique mais bien sûr
que si on accompagne les employés on
leur fait oublier qu'ils ont bientôt et
qui s'insère non pas du tout non non
c'est pas du tout le temps des vous dit
comment pour les plans sociaux chez vous
redéployer polarisé tromper on est dans
un plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi
ok j'ai pas besoin tout de ma
gueule tant que j'ai envie de virer des
gens c'est tout ce que j'ai pour moi le
jargon bon bon bon bon et non je peux
dire bon
oui oui
alice je peux pas te parler lâche en
rendez vous je sais pas à ça s'il vous
plaît écoutez je ressens la tension
quand je rentre dans l'entreprise
d'accord bon pour l'évacuer ma méthode
c'est la mise en place dans le jeu de
rôle qui va agir comme une soupape sur
les employés les collaborateurs ont dit
voilà je souligne tout ce qui est
ridicule et ça fait du bien à tout le
monde mais pièce qu'elle a raison et qui
veut faire le drh qui effectue la lra
jamais personne qui veut faire des
roaches événement a perdu voulait plus
des rh c'est fini cette libre allez
c'est quoi votre poule pourquoi pas de
clown je ne sais pas bozo flambeau
jouent ceux déjà pris maintenant à un
peu d'imagination les agrafes ou non
allez on quitte l'univers du bureau la
passion camembert vers le cloud mais
super allait mal votre truc là je dis
[Musique]
non je n'ai plus galant mr ouai
camembert le clown on adore camembert le
clown qui pue vous présente son plein
essentielle rigolo oui
[Musique]
je vais pas refaire jones ici donc ça
c'est un exercice qui libère vraiment la
parole des employés chante on improvise
un pc l'entreprise ont enregistré une
vidéo qu'on s'envoie tous pas maintenant
c'est vraiment sympa non ben quoi c'est
un enfer c'est parce que j'aime le cab
moussavi on a des supers collaborateurs
et ensemble on a jamais aux gémeaux
notre prix au super entrepris
[Musique]
en place les synergies mais en fait je
suis bon à ça je voudrais faire ça il
est jamais trop tard j'ai entendu ciel
c'est ça ma voix
[Musique]